Ananta North Carolina jury deadlocked
over the question of officer Michael
Slager guilt in the shooting of an
unarmed black man Walter Scott in the
back the media of course went insane
they claim that this demonstrated that
cops could never be convicted they
suggested the mistrial as a result of
deep-seated American racism the only
reason that Slater wasn't convicted in
this trial was one holdout juror 11
other jurors were ready to convict for
murder the prosecutor in this case
immediately declared her intention to
retry the case as well she showed video
shows the officer shooting Scott in the
back then so answering over to Scotts
prone body handcuffing him and dropping
an object near the body that was taser
the prosecutor argued quote his first
instinct after the shots were fired and
he cuffs a dead Walter Scott was - stage
was to stage the scene
Slager then lied to the cops about the
circumstances surrounding the shooting
he claimed that Scott had charged him
and he killed Scott in defense of his
own life now thanks to one juror we're
supposed to believe that all of America
is systemically racist even though the
governor of South Carolina nikki Haley
issued a statement explaining quote it
is my understanding that there will be
as quickly as possible a new trial where
the Scott family and all of South
Carolina will hopefully receive the
closure of verdict brings instead of
recognizing that the vast majority of
Americans are disgusted with this
mistrial and that the justice system has
yet to even come to a real conclusion on
Slater the media instead use the Slater
case to show America's racist in the
system's evil they points the fact that
virtually no officers are convicted for
murder which makes sense since most
officer-involved shootings occur in
disputed circumstances with criminals
and it's difficult to prove a murder
case against officers absent clear and
convincing evidence statistically
speaking 78 officers have been
prosecuted for killings in the United
States since 2005 just under 30 were in
fact convicted of manslaughter one was
convicted of murder but that just shows
that Americans hate black folks
according to The Huffington Post they
said quote black people have shown time
and time again and even when they're
unarmed or fleeing or completely
innocent and a danger to no one the
people sworn to serve and protect can
still kill them and even when almost
everyone agrees the evidence shows the
officer and the wrong the system may end
up disagreeing the system didn't
disagree here one juror did the system
allows for one juror to scuttle a death
a death verdict that doesn't prove that
the system is racist anymore than the OJ
Simpson trials idiotic verdicts prove
the system was racist against white
people but the media are still searching
for a narrative that shows white
Americans attempting to clamp down on
black Americans they really couldn't be
happier about this
which they believe justifies their
suspicions but most of America is
rightly outraged and Slater will face
trial again and Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show already so much to get
to today you're on a show I have to read
you this is the greatest column in the
history of mankind coming up in just a
second it really is pretty spectacular
but first we have to say hello to our
friends over at Z so so see so is this
is fantastic comedy service if you're
really into comedy if you love and
Netflix and Hulu but you're interested
only in comedy see so is for you it's
399 a month I've got C so from my family
I've got C so my wife and I washers got
the archives of all of SNL all of Parks
and Rec it's got all these new programs
as well that are really first-rate they
have a lot of backlog the British
comedies like the original office the
Ricky Gervais and they also have all
these new series including some that are
quite good again it's it's kind of your
one-stop shop for comedy and given how
much my wife and I need to laugh right
now it's it's been a godsend for us see
so calm is the place to go and it's 399
a months they have a bunch of shows as I
say that are really really good one of
the some of them just a really a bit of
the list instead hit in America with
Jonah ray which is Jonah ray taking you
on a comedic tour throughout America
which is a fake travel show the places
are real but the people are not so it's
pretty funny my wife and I have watched
that a little bit we have watched funny
as hell which is a stand-up variety show
of sorts which is it's also pretty good
and then they're bringing on new shows
all the time right now you can try see
so free for two months when you use the
promo code been at checkout so see so
calm and you get two months free a check
out by using the promo code Ben it is a
great subscription service and it really
is a lot of fun to check it out see so
calm okay so I need to start today with
a column that is just the greatest
column in the history of humanity it's
just spectacular and don't worry we'll
get to Donald Trump and going we'll get
to Donald Trump and and more on carrier
there's a lot of information that's now
coming out we'll get to down--all Trump
in the cabinet that ton tons of news but
this column deserves all of the
attention that I can let have a ship on
it and so does Stephanie Landy
delightful human being who penned this
thing so the title of the column is from
the washing
pose is Trump's election stole my desire
to look for a partner well first of all
if you ever are going on a date with
woman who wrote something like this no
it is going to go extraordinarily poorly
doesn't matter your political
perspective if your dating life is
ruined by the politics of the federal
government then I would suggest that you
need new priorities and this is speaking
of someone who immerses himself in
politics every single day here's the
column in August I went on six dates in
one week I had decided that I was ready
to look for a partner
enough of this dating unavailable men a
half decade younger than me
okay first quick note Washington Post
got some editors a half decade younger
than I they never seriously consider a
relationship with me the column
continues my two children and our needy
dog no I wanted to find an equal Amman
who wouldn't feel the need to step in
and rescue me I didn't need rescuing but
I knew deep down that was only partially
true I often felt the sort of gloominess
that's settled in my stomach starting
from a chaotic afternoon with my
children lasting well into the night
when I pulled the covers tight around my
chin I can't imagine why this woman was
having trouble finding mr. right
as Andrew Clavin is fond of putting it
if you're if you're so confident it's
time to find mr. right perhaps you're
not mrs. right maybe you actually need
to fix yourself first I've been on my
own with my kids for most of the past
decade I have no idea what a supportive
partner would even look like in my house
I imagined it as some sort of potluck we
both bring the things we have to offer
and place them on the table it would be
to multi-task and keep everyone's
schedule on track but sit next to his
ability to fix cars cook or read books
in silly voices then we'd feast of the
store of six first dates I had a long as
two men seemed promising one of them met
me at a brewery we chatted happily
through two beers finally I was out of a
job interview mode I'd fallen into while
sitting across from strangers I relaxed
I laughed and it wasn't the laugh I did
just because it was real says no
romantic stuff deep deep soul-searching
stuff we dated for a few weeks before he
admitted he wasn't ready for something
serious wouldn't you have wanted to dive
I just didn't get a little bit of dating
strategy for folks on the first date you
should find out whether something is
serious or not like on the very first
day my wife and I knew on the first date
that we were both looking for marriage
you know what that did it take us both a
lot of headache here the count continues
two days later the other of those good
dates called me out of the blue we
talked for a while and I asked him to
dinner things we're falling into place a
feast was laid on the table and it
looked delicious but but here's
work it's really good guys it's really
awesome you're gonna get to toss a
bucket but two weeks later the election
happened dawn dawn dawn dawn oh my god
once it was clear that Donald Trump
would be present instead of Hillary
Clinton SiC Steve Meister
I long to gather my children in bed with
me
and cling to them like we would have
thunder and lightning were raging
outside with winds high enough that the
power might go out and then we'd sing
and then we would sing the song from
Sound of Music
about kittens and noodles and such the
world felt that precarious to me like
first of all if Donald Trump being
elected native world feel that
precarious you have no faith in the
American governmental system and also I
would recommend that you take a look in
the mirror Hillary Clinton wasn't in
many great shakes my oldest came out of
her room the next morning show me the
money the Tooth Fairy had left her she'd
unexpectedly had to have a tooth pulled
and so bravely went through it and I
said just think you'll always remember
the day you got a tooth pulled with the
day we elected our first female
president uh-uh-uh you can't let your
kid have have the have the memory of the
tooth balling without you without I mean
I do think that those two things by the
way I are related that if we had had
Hillary Clinton as president and a tooth
polling on the same day there is a
certain amount of some sense that when I
told her trumpet one she protested but
mom you said Hillary is going to win a
lot of people thought the same thing I
said I hugged her a little scared to
send her to school out into the big sky
country of the red-state where we live
what you think people are just gonna go
out and start murdering people who are
democrats in red states sorry it turns
out that the murder rates are hard
largely in this country confined to blue
areas even in red states so I mean if
you if you're worried about the safety
of your kid maybe you shouldn't live in
a blue area 20 minutes later at a
stoplight on the way to drop off my
two-year-old to daycare steam started
creeping out from under the hood of my
car it was Trump Trump did it he somehow
went under the hood of her car and made
the steam emanate my god the man can do
anything
fortunately my mechanics Jeff was nearby
my radiator was cracked in two places
right at the top
I really wouldn't feel comfortable with
you driving in one of the mechanics said
luckily a new radiator could easily be
obtained and installed that day I
thanked them I didn't start crying until
I crossed the street to walk home we had
a few miles to go so I carried my
daughter
I didn't mind carrying her I still had
that urge to cling to her and keep her
close it was cold that morning but the
Sun started warmest enough to remove our
hats
though God was smiling upon us in spite
of Trump Satan halfway home my tears
stopped and my despair grew to
appreciation I have the means to fix our
car I on my own can support my family I
not only have the strength to keep it
together mentally and emotionally lots
questionable but I also have the
strength to carry my daughter home I
have the strength to carry all of us
really I'm dead left can you carry me
cuz I'm tired right now that urge to
cling to my family while keeping our
foundation strong didn't mesh well with
continuing to date the man I'd be seeing
he also has a daughter he too had been
feeling a lot of the same emotions I was
experiencing hopelessness fear
uncertainty about the future panic over
having to talk to my 9 year old about
anything that might come up at school or
what to do in the instance of sexual
assault oh yeah hold on hold on so you
weren't going to talk to your daughter
about sexual assault if the first
gentleman actually raped people but you
were definitely going to have to talk
about it now because Trump or something
says but I couldn't reach out to him
anymore this new guy he was too new too
unfamiliar yeah you sound like a pillar
of strength lady and my focus had to be
on my community of friends that are my
family I need to fiercely love the
people close to me instead of learning
to love someone new to reach out to
others could weaken the bonds that hold
my family together I can't I told him I
just can't
I've lost the desire to attempt the
courtship phase the future is uncertain
I'm not the optimistic person I was on
the morning of November 8th wearing a
t-shirt with nasty woman written inside
a red heart yeah who wouldn't want to
date this who it looks seriously what's
wrong with that nutty guy wants to date
this goodness gracious but I went on a
date and some woman showed up wearing a
political slogan said nasty woman on ugh
oh my god get me the hell out of here as
fast as possible it makes me want to cry
thinking of that of seeing my oldest in
the shirt I bought her in Washington DC
that says future president I don't
understand she can't be present anymore
cuz Hilary wasn't we didn't elect the
the crazy old crone lady who was corrupt
in every conceivable way so your
daughter can't be President now and
really if you put this is this
idolatrous worship of politics I mean it
sucks on both sides and it's really bad
on the left Wow there is no room for
dating in this place of grief dating
means hope I've lost that hope in seeing
the words president-elect Ron all hope
is lost cling to your loved ones
Trump becomes for the
like they're people like me we're not
real big on the Trumpster okay like as
you may have noticed I think Trump does
a lot of stupid things I think he does
some smart things I think the Trump does
a lot of bad things I think he does some
good things I think he's a mixed bag but
goodness gracious I mean like you can't
take care of your kid cuz you're so
upset about Trump you can't you have to
cling to your loved ones hide beneath
the blankets Trump is coming and then
you see the windows rattling oh my god
windows are rattling you look outside
boom there's this crazy face with the
hair and all oh boy I think the left is
a little melodramatic about their
politics just a little bit over the top
just a little bit oh goodness gracious
goodness gracious you know not to like
the outcome of elections mean I was very
upset when it turned out the two
nominees from the parties or people I
couldn't stand but I somehow went on
with my life somehow
but I still had date night somehow we
still brought up our kids somehow I
didn't feel the need to talk to and a
half-year-old that her life in America
was over the country was finished it's
just amazing amazing how over the top
two folks on the left are okay so so I
just had to share that with you because
it's wonderful Brody conceivable way it
is it's just it's too it's too glorious
okay so next onto on to Trump so Trump
this morning did something that is very
smart now I think that Republicans are
about to run into a pretty significant
conundrum and it's a conundrum that I've
been sort of loathe to to cover because
it's not clear yet if Trump's gonna be
popular or not but I think he's actually
making some very very smart political
moves moves that are likely to make him
more popular than he is now he's a
headline generating president he's a
president who cares
almost solely about headlines that's a
pretty good way to become popular if
you're just reactive to the headline so
there's a headline and it says carriers
leaving so the first thing you do is you
brandish a club and you tell carrier to
get back in a line and then you get a
good headlines there's a poll out today
that shows 60% of Americans are more
likely to like Trump after the carrier
deal there's also a headline today worth
noting the carrier is raising its prices
that is not a coincidence when you force
carrier to absorb additional costs in
the form of work in the United States
their prices will go up presumably they
will lose business or presumably you'll
have to pay more for an AC piece of
machinery but in any case the fact is
that that made Trump popular so Trump is
now carrying that logic forward he's
just
do a bunch of things that have no real
ideological route to them other than
they make Trump popular and he feels
like doing what he wants and this is not
something I'm a fan of you know I did I
talked to last week about this
philosophy of pragmatism pragmatism
isn't a philosophy pragmatism is the
basic idea that you are independently as
president of the United States capable
of solving all problems and therefore we
should hand you ultimate power you can't
be pragmatic unless you have power if
you ask me to fix your window you it
gave me the power to fix your window you
can't tell me that you want me to fix
the window and then I have to go through
a whole rigmarole in order to do it
people who say therefore pragmatist
presidents really mean therefore
therefore tyrannical presidents they
want a president with the power to do
anything they want the president to do
that's sort of the the mode from which
Trump operates he thinks I alone can
solve and that means that he's actually
going to probably be kind of popular
because he will solve some problems that
are in the headlines while creating new
problems that don't see the headlines
that the problem with the carrier deal
as I said and problem with some of the
other actions Trump is about to take is
that these are things that have some
very good headlines because there's a
clear beneficiary in this case the
people working a carrier but there are a
lot of diffuse victims so all the people
have to pay additional taxes in order to
pay the subsidy all the other companies
who didn't get the subsidy and a have to
compete with carrier all the people who
would be making money in other branches
of United Technologies and now the money
has to be delegated to paying these
people in in Indiana so it's that there
are all sorts of diffuse costs this is
what the great economist Basquiat said
and when you talked about infrastructure
projects his basic take was government
always wants to build roads and
infrastructure every dollar that spends
on a road comes from every job that's
created by government is job taken away
from somebody and that's the reality but
but that's said all of this stuff
actually makes Trump more popular not
less so today's exercise in Trump's kind
of brilliant populism comes courtesy of
Boeing so Trump tweeted this today
here's Trump's tweet and he tweeted
about Boeing thusly
he said Boeing is building a brand-new
747 Air Force one for future presidents
but costs are out of control more than
four billion dollars cancel order so
aside from the kind of hilarity of
Donald's from trying to cancel an a
federal contract on Twitter
it isn't really really smart political
movement it's a very smart political
move because it looks like he's trying
to
waste and fraud and it also looks like
he's trying to do it even at his own
expense he I'm the president and I'm
giving up my fancy new plane in order to
cut waste and fraud never buying the
trillion-dollar infrastructure package
I'm pledging I'm trying cut waste and
fraud with regard to Air Force One now
number one couple couple minor issues
one we don't actually know where the
waste and fraud is in this particular
contract or even if there is waste and
fraud Air Force one contains an enormous
amount of new technology
every time the updated Air Force one
hasn't been updated in thirty years
that's not to say this is the best
contract or the most necessary contract
it's just deployment yeah I'd like to
see the contract at Trump signs to
replace this one for the update of Air
Force One but this is really smart stuff
and here's what Trump had to say when he
was asked about it at Trump Tower today
let's clip 17 this morning about
canceling the contract for the new Air
Force one is that the man seriously well
the plane is totally out of control it's
going to be over four billion dollars
for Air Force one program and I think
it's ridiculous I think Boeing is doing
a little bit of a number we weren't
going to make a lot of money but not
that much money okay thank you
so the so great politics right smart
politics because now it looks like he's
just trying to to get rid of bad
contracts you know the general idea that
there are a lot of people who are
protesting about what he said there
where he says we want boeing to make a
lot of money but not that much money
there are some people saying well that's
the equivalent of obama saying that he
doesn't want companies making too much
money not quite the same thing because
here you're talking about a federal
contract under the purview of the trump
administration so if you said that
broadly if he said broadly we don't want
people making too much money then you're
in trouble I mean that's what Obama said
but if he's just saying in this federal
contract we think that we're being
charged too much we want to renegotiate
the contract that's not the end of the
world very smart politics worth noting
Boeing did take a significant hit the
stock market this morning they're down
at 64 cents in their stock price just
because Trump said this and again I'd
like to see if there's a better contract
available is there a better contract
available so this is good if there's a
better contract available it's not
politics even if there is no better
contract available because it looks like
Trump is standing tall to the to the
evil corporations and we're going to
save on waste and fraud this sort of
headline seeking stuff from Trump is
very often smart politics there's
another example yesterday
Donald Trump meets with Al Gore so the
entire right is is upset about this we
think it's very silly why is Al Gore
this hoaxster with regard to climate
change and he is because his solutions
even if you believe in man-made climate
change and there is some evidence to
suggest that it's true there's no proper
solution to it and certainly the carbon
credit scheme that Al Gore has gotten
rich off of is a scam and all of the
predictions that Al Gore has made about
the climate over the past decade in An
Inconvenient Truth all of those have
turned out to be exaggerated or false
Al Gore goes and he meets with Ivanka
and then he meets with Trump directly
and here's the reality Donald Trump has
spent his career telling a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people on policy in 2009 : think first
solution to climate change is a
full-page letter in The New York Times
very much tube left on climate change
and then swiveled on it and now
apparently he's sort of swiveling back
Al Gore comes out he says that was a
really great meeting loved it really
terrific the bulk of the time was with
the president like Donald Trump I found
in an extremely interesting conversation
and to be continued and I'm just gonna
leave it at that
thank you so here's the deal did Al Gore
goes to Trump Tower and he comes out and
suddenly Trump he looks like he's
willing to hear from the other side now
people on the right are not particularly
happy about this we think Al Gore is a
fraudster but does that really matter
very much for Trump not really he knows
that everybody on the right is in meshed
in his halo effect right everybody is so
excited that he won everybody is so
excited that Hillary lost that they're
willing to kind of brush this off no big
deal now to be fair we wouldn't done the
same thing with Jeb Bush wouldn't have
done the same thing with Rubio or Cruz
if any of them had said you know what
I'm meeting with Al Gore we just said uh
no you're not no that's a bad thing
Trump does it and now it's okay
and again its popularity as substitute
for Princeton football is doing a lot of
things to make himself popular and more
broadly appealing which is smart for him
but I'm not sure that it's smart for
Republicans and not yet and it's
certainly not conservatives who have
actually care about principle because
Trump is doing all these things that are
popular it's very easy for people to get
sucked into the game of mistaking
popularity for truth its mistaking
popularity for principle Kellyanne
Conway tweeted out that poll that I
mentioned earlier about the popularity
of the carrier movie and what I tweeted
back was I was unaware the popularity
amounts to doing good right
when Barack Obama did things that were
popular but we didn't like them we said
those are bad things to do people forget
this but in February 2009 when Obama
first took office he proposed the 800
billion dollar stimulus package that
thing had 60% approval 60% right the
exact same number as the carrier Deal
60% approval for that according to the
Gallup poll taken in February 2009 and
then later it turned out to be a
boondoggle was a good policy cuz it was
popular of course not
popularity never means that something is
automatically good Justin Bieber is
popular does that mean the Justin Bieber
is a quality musician and Kim Kardashian
is popular does that mean the Kim
Kardashian is some sort of whiz kid it's
easy to get sucked into this in politics
because again we tend to see politics as
team sport is our team winning or is our
team losing so Rush Limbaugh sort of
made this argument yesterday the Trump
is winning he's winning big Lee and
because he's winning big Lee that means
that we have to give him a green light
on a lot of the stuff he's doing he says
what offends with truckers rush
yesterday Trump is not on defense folks
we are on offense with Donald Trump and
that's one of the reason of the big
invisible unspoken reasons why he has
such loyalty is because people who
support him are just like a lot of you
in this audience fed up with being on
defense and being on a team that never
fought back much less won on offense but
these tweets and this erratic or
unpredictable behavior keeps
Trump's opponents on defense and believe
me it is a delight
okay and then so so Rush loves the fact
listen I like the fact that if you were
conservative I love the fact that he was
on offense to him as you know my basic
strategy on policies never be on defense
always be on offense so I agree with
Russia's general tenor here my only
question is is he on offense in favor of
good things or is he not on offense in
buffet in defense of good things like
the tactics I can appreciate I'm saying
right now he's what he's doing right now
tactical he's actually quite brilliant
he's picking issues off the tree
headlines off the tree and then he is
using those headlines in order to boost
his own popularity and then 5:00 in the
morning sets the agenda for the day with
some tweet that drives the practice
totally insane it's actually quite
brilliant what he's doing what he's
doing is effective no question it's not
attention rush
went ahead and praise the one trillion
dollar stimulus package Trump is
apparently planning Trump actually
follows through on this trillion dollars
to modernize airports you're going to
have conservative arguments against it
claiming this is not how it works this
is still federal spending it's still
budget busting it's still massively
expanding the government however there
will be tangible results and if Trump
does this and if there are witness Abul
demonstrable results of modernization at
airports you're going to be hard-pressed
to get people to find a problem with it
okay but it's your job to explain why
that's a problem right as a conservative
it's Russia's job to then go on only
he's wrong about the political benefits
of from doing it but it's his job as a
conservative to now explain it not just
as a third party sort of observer Rush
goes well you know some conservatives
will find problems with it why will they
find problems with it explain why is
this bad or are you going to pretend
that it's not that bad because Trump's
doing it and it's popular Mike Pence is
doing the same thing Mike Pence was
asked repeatedly on MSNBC today about
Donald Trump's proposal for a 35% tariff
on any company that puts a job outside
the United States which by the way also
encourages companies not to hire up it
actually encourages companies to hire
fewer people because the last thing you
want to do is hire a hundred people you
have to fire 50 an outsourced instead
what you'd prefer to do is start your
business immediately by hiring a bunch
of people outside the country then
you're not outsourcing because you never
fired anybody inside the country in
order to place jobs out of the country
Mike Pence is doing the same thing it
popular Trump won therefore that makes
the policy okay here's what Pence had to
say Donald Trump tweeted about a 35%
tariff on American companies who produce
things and try to bring them back into
the United States those are not
conservatives do you really believe in
those things well I believe I believe
very much that the American people voted
on November 8th for change and change in
our domestic policy and in many ways
change in our economic relationships
around the world I mean the
president-elect ran on a commitment to
renegotiate NAFTA to pull out of the TPP
agreement and the deal with countries in
the Asian Pacific Rim on an individual
basis
negotiate trade agreements you support
American workers and American jobs did
you support TP you know I did but when
when I first sat down with President
Elect we talked about this he pointed to
the fact that whether it's NAFTA or some
of these other large agreements that
when the United States enters into these
agreements with multiple countries and
accountability is very difficult and
getting out of them is very you're a
freak okay so this is so magical right
tell the son he's been converted to
trumpism why because Trump won and I
know that people have voted for Trump
again this logic didn't hold with Obama
it shouldn't vote for Trump I understand
what Trump is doing and yes it's
brilliant politically because all he's
doing is doing what Democrats have done
for 50 years watch I'm going to use a
lot of infrastructure in order to pay
off all my friends and I'm gonna build a
giant Dam and then I'm gonna put my name
on it and it's gonna say FDR right on
the side and then I'm gonna be super
popular right LBJ did the exact same
thing or Eisenhower's freeway system
right all these all these infrastructure
projects are ways of gaining popularity
and it's a way of getting popularity
when you leverage your company that's
not to say it's bad but I've never said
it's bad politics it isn't bad politics
and smart politics but smart politics
and doing the right thing are not
equivalent they're not the same thing
Barack Obama very smart politician
didn't do the right thing there is a
danger here beyond the principle there
is a danger here beyond the principle
and this is a real question for a lot of
conservatives right so it's a real
question for a lot of conservatives and
that question is what happens if Donald
Trump does his day to day pragmatism
routine he generates a lot of good
headlines for himself but his overall
policy is not good this is what we call
the Obama model where Obama would do
something get a great headline out of it
people would like him people would think
he's great on Kimmel and then his
overall policies really at the top like
mama care right his big world changing
policies kind of suck so you do
something no he's looking look at Obama
now he just went and he helped this this
poor family from Wichita and then he
would go out and put your policy that
affects all Americans and we think it
stinks we don't punish Obama because we
like Obama because he's had all of these
great headlines we punish the Democrats
and so the Democratic Party ends up
hollowed out from the inside right
everybody else pays the price for Obama
for Obama's bad economic policies
Republicans could face the same
conundrum here he had a very popular
president and Trump for example because
he's doing this kind of reactive
politics see something on the new
do something about it see something on
the news do something about it but the
broad policy strokes stink right 35%
tariffs that raise prices on American
goods make consumers pay out through the
nose make American workers pay more
because we use inputs from other
countries create an interest in for
American companies in outsourcing
immediately instead of later and not
hiring enough now because they don't
want to be punished for firing people
later right what if the broad policy
strokes end up with Republicans getting
punished in Congress Republicans getting
punished on the state level Republicans
getting punished in gubernatorial
offices because let's say that these
policies from solution look like the 35%
tariffs end up helping lead to a
recession a Trump is doing fine because
all of his headlines are about what an
activist he is how he's on top of these
things I was taking them one by one
Republicans on a political level are
going to have to actually consider
whether that's worthwhile or not and now
they're stuck between a rock and a hard
place because it lets say the Trump is
very popular and pushing a very
unpopular policy but he's pushing it so
it's more popular but we know that when
it goes into effect it's gonna stink now
what a Republicans do trumple bashed
them over the head in fact he's
activating Kellyanne Conway apparently
to create this this outside government
interest group that is going to just
stump for Trump ISM that's all it's
going to do it's going to help primary
his opponents and it's going to punish
people who don't agree with him and it's
going to be sort of this this
large-scale organizing for action style
Barack Obama campaign to continuing
campaign organization now this is a
conundrum for Republicans it's a big
problem for Republicans and it's
something they're going to have to
consider well before we before we move
on I have to say hello to our
advertisers over Birch gold so again if
you're looking at some of these economic
policies and they're worrying you if
you're concerned that we're headed
toward some economic policies that are
clones damaged the economy that are
going to raise prices that are going to
make things more expensive it would be
worthwhile for you to take some of your
portfolio and invested in precious
metals Birch gold can do that for you
they help you convert your 401k or your
IRA to a 282 precious metals without any
sort of tax consequences
it's birchgold.com slash Ben
birchgold.com slash Brown there's a 16
page free kit now that they will send to
you ask all of your questions get all
your answers and then when you're ready
to invest in precious metals
and talk to my friends over at Birch
gold they're the folks that I would
trust and yes I do have money invested
in precious metals because everybody
should have at least a little bit of
money invested in precious metals as a
hedge against government intervention
ISM okay so the big question for
Republicans is going to be will they
stand up to Trump or should they
politically stand up for Trump and this
is a sort of strategic question which is
how do you hope to get the best out of
the trump presidency do you get the best
out of the trump presidency by calling
him out when he makes a mistake or do
you assume he's going to do some bad
stuff and some good stuff and you push
him to further power because you hope
that the good is going to outweigh the
bad that's a real tactical question all
I can say is that trusting a politician
too much has never ended well
trusting a politician variety you tend
to do more good than bad comes along
with a lot of bad and calling out
politicians for doing the wrong things
seems to be a more intellectually
coherent and politically advantageous
position now as we continue we're going
to continue over at daily wire.com so if
you we have to let go on Facebook and
YouTube but go over to daily wire calm
right now to subscribe $8 a month will
get you a subscription just ditch that
one hamburger
it'll make you skinnier it also make you
wiser $8 a month daily wire.com annual
subscription you buy it right now you
get my novel true allegiance you get
that sign you get access to the mailbag
which is of course the most phenomenal
mail bag the rubber ones we'll be doing
that on Thursday we have all sorts of
new goodies coming for members including
a Members Store which is coming in just
a few weeks you get big discounts if you
remember make sure you go over to daily
wire comm right now and sign up we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
United States
[Music]
you